you know a few screens before school
what anytime dude my cable you get
stupid your daddy's house tonight and
mommy get some alone time I know this is
kind of last minute we like to do these
fun mom dinners well yeah that would be
really nice
all righty okay if I invited Kate Kate
doesn't usually do something us other
moms really I'm babysitting tonight so
you can go out and have fun it's not
babysitting when they're your kids
sorry I can't come alone my life
revolves around a kid I just wanted a
night Nina
oh wait what should we talk about Kate
what can I say I'm mom doubt Melanie I'm
sorry
I know you don't like me my problem with
you is that you walk around like you're
- they took my phone yesterday you
texting the drive I was buying milk a
mother can never run out of milk
you know army of Scots three thinkers
like you
[Music]
anything you want
we've got it if we don't have it we'll
grow it we should set them up with our
selection of stuff that's for mothers
yeah yeah
be cool you didn't say anything just cuz
it's you know it's very illegal sounds
good it'll stabilize that happy fun oh
good idea and I'll take Andrew and he
can tell Tom
[Music]
[Applause]
guys we're locked out until mom gets
home but the good news is got candy
where's Luke he was here with my friends
where'd they go what is it was I
[Applause]
[Music]
dude this is not good
never have I ever had real mom
[Music]
you